gentlemen i really want to start this
interview off by saying how much i loved
this movie
this is what we call one of those
special films that
people are just going to freak out over
um i really am curious for the three of
you guys
who did end up ruining the most takes
from laughing at the dialogue
i don't know but these two gentlemen
here are definitely responsible for some
of those laughs
uh probably the vast majority weasel
is also someone who ruined a lot of
takes
in how hilarious weasel is to witness
doing what he does
um you know i think equally i mean we're
all pretty terrible
at cracking uh so
i don't know i don't know if anyone can
like really wear that badge but i
i would say weasel ruined the most in in
how much he made others
uh lose their [ __ ] i would say the rest
of us failed
when flula needed quiet i would say we
all of us ruined some takes i let me
reassure you nathan my goal
is to win the oscar of cutting room
tables
and cutting room floors so i want no one
to know
anything i've ever done ever i just
wanted to like enigma
except you don't you remember the band
enigma
i didn't do the dancing yes yeah i want
that except no one knows who i am
good that's high aspirations
uh one listen i i think that this movie
as i said
it's just fantastic and i think it stems
from james gunn's script
it takes so many left turns that you're
not expecting
for each of you guys can you sort of
talk about what you think fans are just
going to love about this script
and maybe what's your favorite part of
his writing these are bad guys these are
the villains
we know they're not supposed to win we
know we're not supposed to root for them
we know that's we are steeped in story
trope we know how stories go these are
the bad guys
we start hating them we end up
in a different place this we you you
will feel for these people
you will feel for them yes yeah i think
that's kind of
i was kind of going to echo that in just
saying that i i love that james weaves
such
kind of heart and soul into this um it's
not gratuitous in anything in any sense
but it's
[ __ ] violent and um there's a lot of
blood and guts
he injects uh i mean there's so much
humor
in here but it also kind of um there's a
darkness and a truth to it and
um yeah man it's just uh you
there's no way audiences won't kind of
connect with these characters
um they're a bunch of freaks and misfits
um
but we see the human side in all of them
uh even when they're not
and um and i think that that that'll
leave people with a really special
experience
it's also like you know uh visually
[ __ ] incredible um yes yeah yeah
james has this skill of making you care
about characters which is in my
view the most important thing you can do
on any show if you don't care about the
people then who gives a [ __ ]
but as soon as you care about them you
can do anything you like
and the sassy news is james gunn did
everything he
um i i love learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of a movie
uh i would imagine this was a blast what
can you share about the making of this
film
that maybe isn't in the press notes that
maybe people haven't heard about
clearly costumes are a huge part of the
film
um it takes a great deal of uh time
and skill to make these kinds of
costumes it takes
a span of time they actually rushed the
production of this movie to get it
started quickly the the wardrobe
department i was i was very curious
about the costumes
the wardrobe department worked overtime
to get these things red d day
of like it was an intense schedule for
them
i don't think you're going to know too
much about that
yeah they're amazing um as we're you
know all the creative departments really
um
i mean i think probably something that
is in the press notes is how much
physical set we worked on and there
wasn't a ton of like green screen and
stuff
obviously with exceptions to certain
characters and stuff we had to create
digitally but um
you know we spent a lot of time
submerged in water at the top of the
film and that was all on a beach that
was built
uh which was incredible um you know
having having waves lap ashore
on the back lot of a a a a sound stage
in
um atlanta is a totally weird thing
um but we got to do that uh and i'm so
grateful that this is the space i get to
[ __ ] call my you know profession when
we get to go and work on these things it
really is a true privilege
um we just had a great time to it's one
of those sad
cheesy things people just gonna have to
accept about this movie
um and the you know the the scandalous
stories will never reveal
because um we have to protect one
another at all costs
um i think crimes were committed uh
but you know you don't need to know
about that [ __ ] and um we came out the
other side
alive and kicking i really mean it
congratulations on this
uh people are gonna love it i think
you're right and i can't wait to push it
out
love i want to stress that word thank
you stephen man seriously
it's always weird like i don't believe
they they exit me
stay stay [ __ ]